(upbeat instrumental music)
- What up, guys?
Helen here to talk about the film
that convinced you to create
a new fake Gmail account
so you could try to nab another one
of those recently
discontinued HBO Max trials.
That's right, "Wonder Woman 1984."
Now, like most of you, we were big fans
of the first "Wonder Woman"
and we're naturally
stoked about the sequel.
And while plenty of people
thought the movie was fun,
others were a little disappointed.
And while people might
want to nitpick plot holes
or action sequences,
we at Wisecrack thought
we'd try to learn something
about screenwriting by
asking the question,
"'Wonder Woman 1984,' what went wrong?"
And of course, spoilers
ahead for a brand new movie
and a rather old British story.
But before we get into it,
I wanted to take a second to tell you
about Wisecrack's Patreon page,
which is sort of like a secret island
of highly trained Amazons
but for people who can't help
but search for meaning in pop culture.
So nothing like a secret island
of highly trained Amazons,
but hey, you can join for as little as $2,
which is also how much it cost
for a set of snap bracelets
back in 1984.
Along with early access
to ad-free versions
of all of our videos, patrons
have access to our Discord,
a place to compare notes
about recent videos,
share memes that only a
Wisecrack fan would get,
and to chat with Wisecrack
hosts and writers
about what they're watching,
reading, and playing.
It also gets you access
to exclusive hangouts
where we talk about recent videos,
what we're currently working on,
and occasionally chat
about our ideal lunches.
So go to patreon.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the
description to join today.
Oh, and did we mention ad-free videos?
That's patreon.com/wisecrack.
And now back to the show.
And now a quick recap.
"Wonder Woman 1984" finds Diana living
in that glitzy decade
working as an archeologist
at the Smithsonian.
There, she and her anxious,
supposedly unlikeable
new friend Barbara study a
seemingly worthless stone
that promises to grant wishes.
Each lady makes a wish.
Diana that her dead boo
Steve was still alive,
and Barbara that she was more like Diana.
And surprise, their wishes come true,
but the stone is stolen
by badman Max Gold,
who basically wishes
for a thousand wishes.
- I wish to be you,
the Dream Stone itself.
- But, of course, there's a catch.
The stone giveth and it also taketh.
Diana loses her powers,
Barbara her humanity,
and Max the moist air
entering his nostrils.
Oh, and maybe also his kid.
Then Max goes full Oprah on wish granting
sending the world into chaos,
and it's up to Wonder Woman to stop him,
not with violence but with
(dramatic instrumental music)
the truth.
Now, lots of people have
their various reasons
for liking or disliking this film.
But we think one of the best ways to look
at the film's flaws is through
its central narrative engine.
- The monkey's paw.
- Now, it doesn't take
a Film Studies degree
to see what the film is trying to say.
It's pretty clearly telegraphed
in the opening flashback,
which sees a young Diana
try to win an Amazonian race
by taking a shortcut.
Sneaky shortcuts, Robin Wright warns us,
equal very, very bad.
- You cheated, Diana.
- But, but that-
- That is the truth.
That is the only truth
and truth is all there is.
- [Helen] Anyway, this
quickly becomes a lens
to view the greed-is-good
mentality of the 1980s
or America's general love
of get rich quick schemes and grifters.
- [Max] Do you have
everything you've ever wanted?
Aren't you tired of always
wishing you had more?
- [Helen] Get it?
Cheating your way into
wealth is just as bad
as cheating in an Amazon race,
and it's up to Diana to
set the record straight.
- This world was a beautiful
place just as it was.
And you cannot have it all.
You can only have the truth.
- Now for many at Wisecrack,
this moment felt a little dumb.
Like after hearing those words,
Bernie Madoff wept a single tear
and apologized to all of his victims.
But part of the reason
it might have felt hollow
is the nature of the wishing stone itself.
Supposedly created by some sinister god,
all we know is that it is indeed a trick
which gives you your wish
while also taking away
something very important to you.
In this way, the stone
is indeed a monkey's paw,
as Steve rightly points out
while casually possessing
the apartment, body, and genitals
of an innocent, unsuspecting engineer.
But what even is a monkey's paw?
Well, that term just so happens to come
from a short story of the same name
by British writer W.W. Jacobs.
Published in 1902,
the tale chronicles the unfortunate events
that befall one family
after they wish upon
their friend's shriveled
little monkey appendage.
Despite being warned by said friend
to pitch it onto the fire
again like a sensible man,
the patriarch of the family,
who notes that he has basically
everything he needs in life,
wishes for 200 pounds,
because why dream big, right?
The next day their son
dies in a factory accident
and the couple receives 200 pounds
in whoopsies money from his employers.
The distraught matriarch
convinces her husband
to use the second wish to
bring their son back to life.
But upon hearing the zombified
son knocking at the door,
the spooked-out dad uses the
third wish to kill him again.
Yes, that's the end, and
the moral of the story.
Careful what you wish for.
The whole thing is basically a screed
about not messing with fate.
If the Old Man upstairs
wants you to have 200 bucks
to blow one Funko Pops,
he would have already turned
your hot water back on.
It has since, obviously, become a trope.
- This aftershave made women want me,
but it also made me impotent.
- So how does "Wonder
Woman" botch this trope?
Well, if we consider the
original simian wish fulfiller,
some of "Wonder Woman's"
problems reveal themselves.
In the story, the father's wish is granted
at the literal expense of his son's death,
thus punishing him for
wishing for anything
in the first place.
His son dies, he earns 200 bucks.
Wish granted, you dummy.
And next time, don't (beep) with fate.
The monkey's paw often works best
when it uses narrative
events to show the character
that the thing they want, i.e. wish for,
is not the thing they need, i.e. lose.
- I lost (crying) my greed.
I deserved it.
- Now, that's fitting because
a key screenwriting rule
is to establish your character's
want versus their need.
Your poor character spends the whole movie
pursuing their want
only to learn at the end
that the conflicting
need is more important.
Like how in the 1988
Tom Hanks classic "Big"
he wants to grow up.
- I wish I were big.
- [Helen] But needs to learn
to appreciate his childhood.
Monkey's paws are a supernatural
vehicle to get characters
to realize, sometimes
tragically, what they really need
instead of what they originally want.
And this brings us to the
thing about "Wonder Woman"
that kind of bums us out.
That's because the movie has very little
of the cause and effect
that can make monkey's
paws stories compelling.
The Bilalian King of Crude's dilemma
is probably the closest we get
to a real monkey's paw situation.
He asks to get his land back.
This results in a wall being built.
- I wish for things one cannot attain.
- Like what?
(dramatic instrumental music)
- All of my land to be returned.
- Wish granted but that
wall cuts tons of people off
from their homes and water supply
and makes them want to kill him.
We get real narrative
consequences of his actions,
a real careful what you wish for
with some extra poetic justice.
But even that's a little sloppy.
The movie slaps on the
additional consequence
of Max stealing his security team.
Diana's trade-off is a
little more nonsensical.
It seems like the
filmmakers wanted to say,
"Diana wants her lover back,
"but she needs to accept the truth
"and not cheat at anything ever.
"And I swear to god, Diana,
"if you even think about
hustling men at bars
"with arm wrestling challenges,
"the universe will take
away your power so fast."
If bringing back your dead lover
and consequently losing your
powers seems a little random,
well, it is.
The idea is basically just
lazily shoe horning the story
into the classic superhero dilemma
of how do you get laid more
than once every 50 years
and also successfully saving the world?
Now, this dilemma is perfectly
embodied in the narrative
of Tobey Maguire-era "Spider-Man,"
which puts superheroing
into inherent conflict
with being with Mary Jane.
- [Peter] She looks at me
every day, Mary Jane Watson.
Oh boy.
If she only knew how I felt about her,
but she can never know.
- [Helen] But in this film,
it doesn't actually develop.
Diana's wish doesn't
cause a chain of events
that happen to take away her powers.
It's just a magical trade-off
we have to kind of accept.
And so, when Diana ugly
cries over giving up Steve
and instantly becoming
strong, it feels kind of meh.
(sweeping instrumental music)
- I can't say goodbye.
- For the film's main characters,
the monkey's paw functions less as
a be careful what you wish
for because it might come true
and much more of a haphazard
trading one good thing
for one random (beep) thing.
This is pretty clear in
Barbara's trajectory.
Now early on, her character is
depicted as a pathetic loser
who magically becomes hot, likable,
and able to walk in heels.
But for wishing to be like Diana,
the monkey's paw takes its payment
in the form of stealing her humanity,
aka turning her into a
stone cold, violent asshole.
But what's her sin in the first place?
Accidentally wishing to
be an immortal superhero?
See, her initial wish,
unlike asking for a nuclear
arsenal or free money,
seems so much less problematic.
- I do you know what I'd wish for.
To be like Diana.
- She doesn't want to be suddenly famous.
She just wants to be strong, sexy,
and liked by her coworkers,
not even in a "Black Mirror"-esque,
obsessed with your social score way.
Just like a normal human way.
Her powers are completely
accidental to the wish.
So what really is the message?
That she needs to just accept
being sad, lonely Barbara
about whom the office
bros needlessly talk shit?
Now maybe the message is
that Barbara needs to learn
self-confidence the hard way,
by scrolling through
the social skills Reddit
or going to an out-of-network
therapist once a week.
But the film doesn't say that.
Instead, Diana is all-
- 'Cause you're not the only one
who imagined a world were
everything is different.
- [Helen] Basically,
the message feels like
Barbara should have just
been content with her lot.
Again, just kind of weird
and even a little mean.
And what, only Amazonians
get to be popular?
It's worth noting that
the monkey's paw mechanics
at the end of the film
are a little bit better.
People want unearned stuff with no regards
for the consequences and, en masse,
this narratively launches
the world into a nuclear war.
- Soviets' early detection
system have picked up
our new nukes.
- [Woman] What new nukes?
- 100 warheads just went
online ready to launch.
They're taking this as an act of war,
prepping to return fire.
- So greed is bad. Yay.
But perhaps the strangest thing of all,
there actually is a pretty interesting
monkey's paw situation for Diana
that's baked right into the plot.
Now, we're not typically in the business
of suggesting punch ups,
but indulge us this once.
The screenwriter's choice
to bring Steve back to life
in another man's body has
confounded the internet
and made us a little
existentially concerned.
Is this guy still alive while
this stone cold hottie lives,
breathes, and sexes in his body?
Is he stuck in the white
man's sunken place?
It's never explained and Wonder Woman,
despite supposedly being the greatest,
most moralist person in the world,
seriously doesn't seem to give a (beep)
about romantically
borrowing the body of a dude
who is, for all intents and purposes,
spiritually blackout drunk.
But it actually really easily
could have been explained.
The real monkey's paw
consequence all along
could have been that Steve
possessing another man's body
was the careful what you wish for.
That is to say Diana's real
struggle could have been
whether or not she could
possibly live with herself
if she brought Steve back
to life at the expense of a,
by all accounts, perfectly
nice seeming engineer
with a messy apartment.
She wants her boyfriend back,
but she needs to abide by her moral code
of not doing a "Get Out."
- I want your eye, man.
- But the most interesting consequence
of bringing Steve back to life is entirely
and very awkwardly ignored.
Instead, the stakes are incongruently
just about Diana losing her powers
and convincing everyone in
the world to accept their lot
because messing with
fate can ruin your body,
mind, soul, et cetera.
And for everyone else's wants and needs,
Barbara wants to be cool but
learns that she needs to accept
being a nerd because the
alternative is being a huge (beep).
Steve wants to be with Diana,
but he needs to be dead.
Max Gold wants a ton of wealth
but learns that he needs his health?
Oh, and also on top of that,
he seems to randomly realize
that he also super needs his son,
a revelation that is basically mandated
by Diana's lasso of truth.
So not exactly the most
exciting character growth.
While the film has been
hailed in some reviews
as being hopeful and
optimistic about human nature,
all we're really seeing
is a superhero film
in which the superhero makes
the world a better place
by magically convincing all
humans to stop being greedy
over the span of a mediocre speech
that sounds like a yoga
teacher's Instagram caption.
I mean, if your suspension of disbelief
wasn't already broken, it surely was now.
We're not saying that every superhero film
needs to be cranky about
human nature in the end,
but this movie puts a rose-colored lens
over an ultimately kind of,
no, actually very cynical worldview,
which is that we should accept
the (beep) of our given lives
because as Diana puts it.
- And you cannot have it all.
You can only have the truth.
And the truth is enough.
- [Helen] The film wants
to put forward a critique
of American avarice,
get rich quick schemes,
and the hucksters that run them,
but it needs to figure out how to do that
so that wishing to be
likable isn't a cardinal sin.
What's more, Diana's speech
just feels kind of off.
The truth in this imaginary 1984 world
certainly doesn't seem beautiful.
The president is a doddering
fool who just wants more nukes.
- What is there to wish for but more?
More nuclear weapons, more than they have.
Closer to them.
If I just had that in place
then they would to have to listen to us.
- [Helen] The Middle East is
a very simplistically rendered
(beep) show and there's
plenty of domestic violence
for good measure.
The world may be pretty beautiful
if you're a hot superhero Amazonian,
but expecting everyone
else to agree feels like-
- Even now, you're patronizing me.
- Did "Wonder Woman 1984"
miss the proverbial mark?
And if so, was it because of the bizarre
monkey's paw plot line?
Or are we just grumpy because
of the (beep) vaccine rollout?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to all our
patrons for your support.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're Kristen Wiig
pretty viciously assaulting
a low-key sex predator
and ring that bell like
it's still Christmas.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Peace.
(upbeat instrumental music)